Hello I'm Jonathan Worth from the Connected Academy, today's conversation is between
the photographer Isadora Kosofsky
and subjects from her long-term
documentary project Vinny and David.
Five years in the making, Vinnie and
David takes a humanizing look at
juvenile incarceration through the
dysfunctional lives of two young
brothers and their extended family.
The audience perspective is provided by Peter DiCampo, now Peter isn't someone we'd
readily associate with issues of mass
incarceration or juvenile detention,
but the reason we've asked him to be a part of this conversation, is because of his
role as Everyday Africa co-founder. Now
if you're not familiar with Everyday
Africa it's a collective of
photographers whose mission it is to
provide a fresh perspective of the
continent beyond the usual stereotypes
of war poverty and famine, so when we're
thinking about how images are
interpreted then for me and many like me
that project is stand-out. Make sure you
visit their Instagram page. Pete Brooke
is our subject-specialist and he gives a
contextual overview. Many of us know Pete
from his days writing for Wired, others
know him for his prison photography
project through which he pretty much
defined the genre and word of warning, if
you're new to that blog, it's a
proverbial rabbit hole of the many
different forms of image making that
relate to mass incarceration. The
conversation you're going to listen to
is particularly rich and like all the
talking pictures sessions there are a
bunch of different ways that you can
unpick it. Our primary question for this
week is, who are you talking to? And
thinking in particular about how the
audience will interpret the material we
present them with. You're going to hear
about Isadora's approach to
storytelling, how she searches out her
subjects and when she finds them, how she builds, and commits to long-term
relationships. You're also going to hear
about how the process of doing the
interviews for this course have affected
Isadora, how they've made her reflect on
the impact she's had on her subjects and
as you listen to it, it's worth
considering how our approaches to
storytelling affect the story itself.
You're going to find that context is a
recurring theme in this talk in many
different guises. As you listen to
Felicia describe her incomprehension at
why anyone would want to see photographs
of their lowest moments, we might also
ask ourselves what are the moments we've
considered photographs to be unnecessary
or inappropriate?
Are there moments in life where
photography is entirely obsolete and how
might that change with context? What are
the contextual ingredients required for
the mundane to become interesting? Or,
of consequence? As in the case here where, as Isadora says, they may have a deeper social
resonance and as always don't forget to use the platform to share your notes and
to comment on other people's. Listen to
the audio in your own time. Take time to
pause, reflect, revisit sections you're
not sure about, and take time to dig
around in the networked class as well.
Investigate other people's notes see
who's making them where and why.
[Isadora] I met Vinny when he was 13 at the
juvenile detention center in Albuquerque
New Mexico and I was intrigued. There was
something striking about how small he
was in stature he was also striking that
he was so,  confident. I followed him into
the unit and he sat by himself in an
empty row of chairs. I sat down next to
him and I asked him what are you doing
here?
[Vinny] I got in trouble for defending my
mom.
[Isadora] He had been arrested for stabbing
the man who was assaulting his mother,
who we had already witnessed for many
year,s being abused by men, and he began
crying.
[Vinny] I defended my mother and the
right way I was taught, in the right way
I knew. Wasn't trying to hurt nobody but
unfortunately, I had no choice
[Isadora] It was an act of heroism, unfortunately the
Police could not prove it to be that and
they arrested Vinny and brought him to
the youth jail. Vinny began telling me
about his relationship with his brother..
[Vinny] Not that  he's not a man I know he is, he's just now, less of a man.
[Isadora]  he told me his
brother wasn't good but he wasn't bad, he
was somebody that he loved and admired,
kind of father figure, and I was
intrigued.
[Vinny] I see two brothers that love each
other unconditionally, but one brother
wasn't there when the brother needed him
to be there, and at that specific moment
the younger brother had to become the
much more mature and older brother.
[Isadora] I had been looking for a family that bared the
dynamics that I was trying to tell in
the juvenile detention facility. I saw
Vinny and I knew that he was going to be
the subject of a long term project and
that is an internal, visceral reaction
similar to
falling in love (?). I knew that he was
somebody that I wanted to know. I wanted
to know about him. I wanted to know about
his mother. I wanted to know about his
brother. It was a curiosity. It was a
connection that I felt burning inside of
me that I had to pursue.
[Jonathan] Prison Photography blog founder Pete Brooke.
[Pete] Every year two million youth are
arrested in the United States. On any
given night there are at least 60,000
children behind bars, some estimates have
as high as 65 thousand. With an average
cost of 80 thousand dollars per year to
lock up a child, the U.S. spends more
than five billion annually on youth
detention. In the more wealthy states
such as California it can cost up to two
hundred thousand per year to incarcerate
a single child.
By contrast spending in the California
public school system ranges from seven
thousand to eighteen thousand per
student, per year. Throughout the 80s and
90s juvenile detention began to mimic
the adult systems.
Lawmakers failed to adequately
distinguish between the transgressions
of adults and the waywardness of youth.
Juvenile systems built facilities that
functioned like adult prisons.
Incapacitation became the mantra and in
such a political climate, rehabilitation
for youth was sidelined or suspended
altogether. During an uptick in violent
crime in the eighties and nineties there emerge a
hysteria about young criminals. They were
brandished super-predators. Feral
teenagers that terrorized society. Of
course this wasn't the case but several
high-profile crimes in the new stoked
public fear and the stage was set for
harsher punishments of youth. In the
United States where race and class are
so tightly intertwined, a
disproportionate number of economically
disadvantaged people are of minority groups.
Poorer people suffer to a greater extent
at the hands of inflexible casual
systems. Minority youth bare the brunt of
youth imprisonment.
Poor white children also have a rough
ride it should be noted,  but if we're to
understand crime and punishment in the
US we must acknowledge its racial bias.
Children from poorer backgrounds are in
some ways set up to fail. For its within
disadvantaged communities that truancy,
acting out, unstable home conditions,
fractured families, sexual and physical
abuse, crimes of need and a host of other
social problems, exist at higher
frequencies. Children from poorer
backgrounds are in some ways set up to
fail. For its within disadvantaged
communities that truancy,
acting out, unstable home conditions,
fractured families, sexual and physical assaults, crimes of need and a host of other
social problems exist in higher
concentration. It is in disadvantaged
communities that many delinquent youth
grow up. Now some children locked away in
the US prison system have caused harm,
but they themselves have been harmed.
They may have victimised people but it
is safe to assume that in most cases,
they are victims themselves.
One does not need to look far to find children in
prison who have been coerced, bullied,
assaulted, pimped or abandoned.
For youth in such dire struggles we need to ask ourselves if prison cells are an
adequate solution to the many many
underlying social problems.
Intervention may be necessary, but all research has shown alternatives to incarceration and
supervision within the community, results
in lower recidivism better treatments,
better education, and more cohesive
relationships, and better Public Safety.
Prisons, especially youth prisons, do not
make us safer.
Do children need punishment or guidance?
Do we want revenge or healing?
And as a society do we want to be retributive or restorative?
[Isadora] When I began photographing
Vinny I knew that I had to photograph David his
older brother as well,
I needed to photograph their mother, I
needed to photograph the entire family
in order to understand Vinny.
I particularly wanted to tell this
intersecting story of the love between
two brothers, because I felt that most
people would not be able to relate to
these stories of incarceration, but I
needed to find a thread that would allow
people to empathize with this family.
It's actually not about telling the
stories of incarceration, it's telling
the stories of what I consider to be
trans-carceral, meaning the walls
extend outside the facility into all
areas of social life. Had I just
photographed Vinny I would have
simplified the story.
[Jonathan] Everyday Africa co-founder; Peter DiCampo
[Peter] To me her work is so much about
what it can teach to an audience, what we
can learn from it and the degree to which
humanising these characters, helps us
understand more about the system of
incarceration as a broader issue. So much
of what she's trying to accomplish here
is a degree of the why basically, you
know, why do these things happen? Why this particular boy? The social factors that
lead up to this, the family factors that
lead up to this.
Issues of incarceration  have been painted a certain way especially in the States and the, the sort of
war on drugs mentality that I grew up
with -  you know criminals and
quote/unquote bad guys are basically
synonymous, in the same way that I feel
the coverage of the African continent
that I grew up with made Africa and
famine and war kind of synonymous. If you
showed incarceration purely as people in
prison, it shows what life in prison is
like, or in this case life in a youth
facility but, it doesn't answer any of our
questions of how did we get to this
point. Of course she moved out of what
she calls the carceral setting because
you have to get into the family life, and
of course,  once you get into their family
life through following her photo essay,
it just teaches you that there's so much
more to the situation.
[Isadora] The biggest hurdle was gaining David, the
older brother's trust, David said to me
"I've never really liked pictures,
pictures don't lie ,a photo is evidence"
that's something that has stuck with me
as I've worked with that family,  that I
needed to make photos into catalysts for
compassion because photography is used as a weapon against families like Vinny and
David's family. I had to show them that
that could be a portal into hope rather
than something that could further
destroy their family dynamic.
[Jonathan] One of the extended family members that became a part of the project was Felicia -
David's girlfriend.
[Felicia] First time you met DJ (David)? Was after you had already met Vinny,
so to meet his older brother, was like,
really intriguing to you. You had a big
smile on your face and you were just so excited and  were like just amazed by it
to meet Vinny's older brother
he always talks so much about. He thought you were CYFD (Child Youth and Family Dept.)
and he closed the door in your face!
[Isadora] He originally didn't want me in his life,
not only because he feared that I
was someone in a position of legal
authority like a social worker for this
state or even a police officer at one
point. He also at one point, feared that I
was going to take his photo and then
vanish with it. And I had to over time
show him that first of all I wasn't just
going to vanish because that's not
within my practice, but also that the
photos in and of themselves negate
abandonment because being able to
document someone's life is seeing them.
[Felicia] I always thought you know this is just  another
person that's going to be in and out of
my life and I'll forget 'n you know a
couple years not even never think of
them again or something and totally did
nothing like that and then glad it
didn't.You became so close with me and
everybody in the family it was like, just
meant so much more.
[Isadora] They, like Vinny,
don't have an understanding that their
story is of value and seeing somebody
return, and show them that they matter, by
returning to take more photos, by
returning to interview more, by returning
to just be in the space with them.
[Felicia] At first honestly I was a little nervous about being photographed by somebody I
didn't know and what my pictures were
going to be used for, who was gonna
see 'em and stuff like that but then,
just became kind of natural have you
take pictures of us. I mean, even at some
of the worst of the worst, baddest times
like it was
natural that we'd let you take pictures
of us and be there and be a part of the family, kinda.
[Isadora] Like Felicia says in her interview I
became a part of that family in a sense
and that they grew to anticipate my
arrival and accepted that I was there
maybe not enjoyed at certain times but
they accepted that I was there.
[Felicia] Sometimes when we were really low or down or
y'know going through rough times and you
would be taking pictures y'know, we're
outside crying or whatever, having drama
and you'd be taking pictures and I would
just be like man! This is really
uncomfortable, like, who wants pictures of
this crazy "drama-ness"? But then after
a while it just was like, very more
meaningful that you were there in those
hard times and took pictures of us then
because looking back at those photos, it
really makes you think, it makes you feel
that again, like and to know that
somebody caught all that emotion in one
picture is crazy.
[Isadora] When she mentioned the
first time that I photographed an
intense sequence of events in a parking
lot it was enlightening and moving to
hear her say that she now realises the
value in the meaning of those types of
photos and how it's in those moments
that people are able to be brought into
this family and able to identify and
empathise with them. Documentary
photography lessens loneliness for its
audience members because it creates
these relatable ties between subjects
and audience. But it also lessens loneliness
for the subject and it is definitely
lessened my loneliness to work on these
stories.
[Vinny]  At that time I had been to my
aunt Becky's and you called and talked
to me and Vicky and asked if you could
come up to take some photographs for us
on our project and she said yeah and you
did show up. That was around the time I
had started being
trustworthy with you like, I knew that
you were trustworthy I should say.
[Isadora] I'm not cognisant of an audience when I'm
starting a project on someone.
Particularly when working on a long term
series you have to shoot for the subject
and you have to shoot in relation to the
curiosity that you have about that
subject. Because at the end of the day
the person most impacted is going to be
the subject.
[Peter] I think the responsibility
that she feels to the subjects in this
case is directly tied in to the idea of
long form journalism of respecting their
vulnerability respecting the power that
she has in this situation.
[Isadora] when I showed the photos to Vinnie in 2014 before
it went live on time.com. I asked him if the
photo essay, the edit, not the photos in
general, the edit that was going to be
published was true to his experience
and he said "Yes", and that's when I knew it
was ready to be shown.
[Vinny] The first time I had actually seen a photograph of me it was in the visitation room with my mother.
We were both crying. The picture
reminds me that that at that moment I
felt down, just downgraded and I couldn't
do nothing. I felt what I said less of a
human, when I see that photo.
[Felicia] their mom cried for weeks and weeks when she saw
that I mean still to this day I bet you
if you brought that, that, your story up
in the project and read it out loud or
were just showing pictures anything, any
part of that project, like his mom would
still cry to this day like and it same
for me like, it's just so meaningful and
sad but yet brings so much joy at the
same time to know that somebody put so
much effort in to tell their story when
it was like, we were the lowest below like who wants
even be around us, see us, let alone care
about what we're going to are
photographing us at the lowest of the
low like, and that that's, that's deep right there
[Isadora] I didn't know that they cried when
they saw the first article through Time.
I didn't know that they cried when they
would look at the photos that I sent and
that has changed the way that I look at
my subjects, because I feel seen. Not only
do they see themselves in my photos, they
also see me.
[Felicia]  I look at things a lot
different now towards journalism and you
know photography than I did when I met
you, but in another sense when I do think
about journalism now or photography I
only think of you.
[Isadora] her love for me was something that was only revealed in the
interview. When I photograph her when I'm
around her there's a level of restraint
that I experience from her. It is a
complex dynamic between that family and
my identity as a photographer. I don't need them and
they don't need me, but I want them, and
they want me, which is I believe a normal
response to a long-term relationship.
[Vinny]  I'm glad that the project happened.
That's what has kept me kept me going this
straight path that I have. Just hearing
everything and seeing everything the way
it was explained it would be. I don't see
an end I do not. Only see the project
getting better therefore I can only do
better. I can only get a job, or a house,
or show you, not you, not the project, not
society, not nobody except my family, that
it won't get better so that we want to
make the project better.
[Isadora] I know that Vinnie mentioned that he
feels that I've, somewhat inspired him to have
a healthy life. I don't know if that's
entirely true), but I am happy to have
been one of the first people to listen
to him and it appears from his interview
that that has greatly affected him that
somebody has shown interest in him.
Someone has committed to his story and
someone has seen his story as a valuable artifact.
[Vinny] I kind of almost questioned why
did it happen? Like, that's the only thing
to say to that. Like why did it happen? I
always had thought you were a beautiful
woman and that was that was the main
thing. You were a beautiful woman and you
were in such a disgusting place and I
did ask questions like, what the heck?
[Isadora] My life has changed since I did that interview with him I have never asked them those
questions and I've worked with them
almost six years. So it has really, really
shaped, not only the way I work, but even
the way that I see myself.
To people listening this may seem odd but in the process that I go through as a
photojournalist I try and overlook that
I feel that I am invisible. I very much
overlook the fact that I am even a
person sometimes when I'm shooting
because I have to be a kind of welcoming
wall. Because I'm in a capacity of using
the photographs to create larger change
than I would be able to in a moment of
reaction in that space, with that family.
[Felicia] I have to say I was a little nervous a
little scared. Like you know, a little
worried about who was going to see the
pictures or what we said about me or, y'know I didn't really understand fully
the whole meaning or process of the
project or whatnot but when it came out
it was it was crazy it was so amazing
and the way the story was told through
pictures like I think touched everybody.
[Vinny] I got pulled over, and I cop had ran my name, and he had came back to my vehicle and he asked me:  "You're Vincent aren't you?"
I said yes sir I am. He goes "you're on the internet for er..
defending your mom and I didn't know
that that was what that was for"
and I said yeah and he goes: "Well good job!" And that brought me confidence.
I think that the photos are trying to show society that,  I am human.
[Jonathan]  I've listened to this now they must be a hundred times and I never cease to be moved by it.
Benjamin Chesterton rounds off the
discussion of Dalia he sees work on "The
Missing" by saying that these
conversations between the subject and
the photographer may be more humanising
than the photographs alone.
I wonder how listening to Vincent and
Felicia has affected your reading of the
work? Do you think the images are an
accurate reflection of the relationship
you've just heard about? There's so much
in that talk and there's a whole lot
more in the extended versions in fact I
think this talk is probably most notable
for how much has been edited out, how
much we've had to edit out because
there's so much great stuff. But I'm just
going to pick up on a few things that
blew me away and we can pick up that
conversation in Twitter, I'm sure there's
lots that you've got to talk about.
There's a moment in there where Isadora
talks about "overlooking her own impact".
In the full interview she talks about
being part of the fabric of the moment
and that's probably a convenient
oversight that most, perhaps all
photographers make it to some degree.
It makes me wonder should we, as
photographers, appear in the frame more
often? I mean, I don't recall an occasion
where a photojournalist appears in their
own image. I mean they're probably some
out there, there's plenty where they
include other photographers perhaps our
nod to the presence of the storyteller.
But none where they themselves
acknowledge their impact. To be clear I'm
not talking about new journalism where
the journalist is at the center of the
story.
I think I'm responding to Isadora
saying that she shoots for her subjects
and her subjects become her friends or
by her commitment to their relationship
her friends become her subjects. She says
she doesn't shoot for an audience, or
that she isn't cognisant of an audience,
more accurately, but we shouldn't take
away from that she isn't mindful of them
I don't think. I mean she's not
photographing in a creative vacuum.
If anything she's hyper-aware of the
audience, I mean she talks about
photography being weaponised. She
might not be shooting for an audience
but I would argue that she's definitely
editing a version of the world for one.
She says, she couldn't limit herself to
images of Vinny in a carceral setting.
That the setting would define the
subject. She introduces us to the notion
of "trans-carceral" and says that she needed to photograph the mother, the brother,
in order to make photographs that act as
"catalysts for empathy" (I love that phrase)
she's looking to make sort of, bridges,
between the subject and the audience.
I'm put in mind of the advice that the
photographer Lisette Modell purportedly
gave to a young Diane Arbus:
"The more specific you are the more general you'll be"
In other words, if you want to talk
about ageing, then photograph your
grandparents, because everyone can relate
personally to the notion of a
grandparent figure and each of us will have "relateable ties",
as Isadora calls them, with the idea of
a mother, a brother, a girlfriend, a
boyfriend, just as we will a warm embrace
or a tearful hug and the catastrophic
loneliness that must come to an isolated,
incarcerated, 13-year old child
I also found a wake up call for me as
the audience I didn't expect that.
My impact.
She says: she didn't know the family cried when they saw the pictures
that's the moment we, as audience, and the subject shared,
they saw their lives re-contextualised. The photographic
equivalent of an out-of-body experience.
They were looking on the story of that time in their lives
but through a third set of eyes
and also for the first time experiencing
those moments without Isadora in them
without the photographer present, think
about that, your subject with whom you've
built a trust relationship and who's
allowed you to make their picture
will be alone in front of an audience
come publication and on one level, your
picture will be a portrait of your relationship with them.
Isadora says, again in the extended
interview, that she feels the social
resonance of the work comes with the
personal connections she forms with
those subjects, and as photographers
ourselves of widely differing ages and
backgrounds I wonder, how do you think Isadora's age (relative to her subjects)
her gender and her race, affect the story?
How important is she? Isadora talks about
her approach to photography "negating
abandonment" which was something of a
revelation to me and both Vinnie and
Felicia refer to the fact that she
returned, that she did what she said
she'd do, and how important that was for
them and then Isadora builds on that by
reflecting on how documentary
photography's "relatable ties" lessen
loneliness for her personally. And the
subject and the audience too.
Perhaps that's a part of the currency of
this work and this way of working, the
photographer
leverages a loneliness that's inherent
in us all. Simon Norfolk says that for
his work, beauty is a seductive tool.
He'll draw the audience in with a
beautiful image so that he can incite
their curiosity about the subject. That's
clearly a currency of photography and a
visual storytelling in general but I've
never really thought of loneliness as
being similar before.
I asked Isadora who needed who the most?
Was it her needing her subjects? Or her
subjects needing her? And I think her
answer is really striking, its where she
says that neither of us need each other,
but I want them and they want me which is,
I believe a normal response to a
long-term relationship.
I mean that makes me wonder again how important Isadora is to this piece of work? I wonder if,
if I could have done it? As a 44 year old white male. I wonder if each of us
different ages, gender, cultural
backgrounds, could have made the same piece of work?
So now is the time to revisit your four corners image prior to submitting it,
but before you do that you
can now access the deep-dive materials
for this session and the full-length
interviews. You'll be able to access the
interview with everyday Africa
photographer Nana Kofi Acqua and hear
him address the courses key questions, all
of them.
And think about, think again about this notion of interpretation. You'll hear him describe why he believes
"the messenger must tune himself to become a reflection of the message".
It's a particularly valuable perspective
coming as he does from backgrounds in
both radio journalism and advertising.
Hopefully we'll see you next week in the
webinar, but be sure to submit your four corners image
in time for it to be
included in the review.
In the next session we're thinking about Fiction, and we'll be talking about the amazing Tim Hetherington
with his Trust's director Steven Mayes.
The Mexico City based photographer Dominic Bracco joins us , and so does Professor of Criticism,
Susie Linfield
I'm Jonathan Worth, and you can connect with me via twitter:
@jonathan_worth